what you're saying is
yeah quantitative easing is good if done
if i would have done it i would have
done it differently right okay so what's
the difference between that statement
you're making versus the socialists and
the communists that say yeah i know
everybody says communism doesn't work
and socialist doesn't work but if i
would have done it i would have done it
differently no it doesn't work
quantitative easing doesn't work
this system doesn't work what they're
doing because again today
we're going to enter i know my
prediction is i've been in the financial
sector for 21 years now i got started
day before 9 11 with morgan stanley i'm
serious 7 6 31 26 life and health this
has been my world for the last 21 years
since i got out of the military okay
am i a ray dalio of course not am i a
economist no am i the guy that went to
mit or any of the universities oxford no
i don't have a four-year degree nor do i
have do i have a two-year degree i'm the
regular guy that's concerned and asks
questions who works his ass off and has
got big dreams and is curious that's
where i'm at so i know my prediction i
may be wrong
shit's about to hit the fan july 1st
it's officially gonna be announced my
prediction is recession okay q3 it'll be
two quarters in a row it'll be announced
it's recession i don't think they can do
anything about it at this point they'll
announce recession july 7 july 14th but
in the first week or second week of july
they're going to announce recession okay
so now they announce it so the powells
of the world and the janet yellens of
the world who are sitting here saying on
october 29th when she did this interview
with wolf blitzer i don't know if you've
seen this before if you can just play
the video i just want people to see the
20 seconds of it so she's supposed to be
the person who's the former fed chair
she's supposed to be the secretary of
treasury she's supposed to be the person
that we all trust and she's brilliant
and she's a genius and she's this
october 29th wolf blitzer rewinded a
little bit and and pause it so they can
hear it on october 29th she says when
she's asked about inflation she
downplays it so watch this here for 30
seconds and yesterday she says sorry tom
go back again because tom spoke so we
must go back a little bit clearly madam
secretary this inflation problem in the
u.s is not temporary right well i still
would say it's temporary although i
don't mean just a matter of a month or
two although monthly inflation rates are
substantial have substantially declined
um from where they were just four or
five minutes secretary to downplay this
information two days ago risk did that
contribute to the problems we're all
seeing right now
well um look i i think i was wrong then
about um you're who we hired inflation
um would take as i mentioned there have
been you can pause this if people want
to see this you can see the rest so
so okay so we go into recession say
first or second week of july
then they're going to come out and
they're going to say oh my god you know
it's a show recession and then they're
going to come out with numbers and what
we have to do is powell's going to come
out with yelling and biting and all
these guys your quantitative easing is
well we have to mix so then we go and
print another three trillion dollars for
it it's not a big deal no one's going to
see it so this keeps getting delayed and
delayed and delayed and delayed because
a guy like you whom i want to believe
you know this is not going to work long
term temporarily it could work but for
us to prevent inflation
i guess where i'm trying to get to is if
we leave it alone we don't do any
quantitative reasoning there's going to
be many guys like you that are going to
say do quantitative easing but i'm not
saying that but not saying but once you
do quantity in fact i've said the
opposite
in since may 2020 i've been warning they
are creating inflation they need to stop
they are creating inflation
idea 95 though yeah but it's for
different purposes it's when you have a
bust banking system after an acid bubble
and you've deflated and now bank credit
is shrinking in 2020 bank credit was
growing already already in february uh
january february by six percent you
don't need this qe the qe was the wrong
policy and i was very clear on that say
we don't do qv say we don't do qv say we
don't do any qv okay uh we naturally let
it said you said a quote in your
documentary that was uh there's not a
country who's changed its social or
economic system without a crisis this is
in your documentary which i recommend
everybody watching right okay sounds
good um
so okay i agree
i actually agree fully with that
statement
but i also think
that we've been extremely spoiled
it's like kids who all of a sudden get
into a rich family and they've been in
it for a while they don't know what hard
work is they don't know what's going on
and then daddy or mommy loses all the
money
and they have to go through the pain
and you can't just band-aid put a
band-aid on it right you kid listen son
we lost everything
yes you have to go get a job you have to
go make money i no longer have that
hundred thousand dollars that i'm paying
you every year as a allowance you no
longer have that kind of luxury that
you've been living for the last 15 years
but dad what are you talking about you
know what am i going to do my girl's
going to leave me she's going to leave
you bro
and you're going to lose a lot of
friends your party but you get all the
tab at the bar you're right you're going
to lose that car of yours that you go on
a date with all the time that you look
hot and you look good you ain't going to
be as cool as you've been the last 10
years the coolest you've had the last 10
years has been fake son son you're
actually not cool
you have to go earn the coolness is what
you got to earn america has millions of
people that have been cool the last 10
years that should not be cool they need
to lose it so for me
if we don't do nothing they're going to
propose another quantitative easing
they're going to propose it
if we do nothing
okay no quantitative easing
and we have to go through this
without anything being put into the
system from federal reserve without
anything being put in the system and
bailing out the next bank that's going
to be going down what happens if we do
nothing and how long will that last
well if already since 2020 they had done
nothing
it would have been much better
because what they created and these were
government decisions and central bank
decisions
is they on the one side restricted the
supply artificially which was
unnecessary and at the same time created
money and gave it into people's hands
and they the federal reserve forced the
banks to increase credit by purchasing
um assets from the non-bank sector so
that puts a lot of money into people's
hands so you restrict supply you
increase demand you create a lot of
money you will get inflation that was
very clear from
may um 2020 onwards and i warned about
this and i said this is wrong and
unfortunately we are still on that path
and it could now move towards
accelerating inflation we have a period
of um stagflation that's being created
artificially and that's the key thing
that means however we can at any time
end this and have proper policies and
the proper policies are
when banks
mainly and and ideally only create
credit for productive purposes
and that is when banks small banks lend
to small businesses for business
investment increase productivity
implement new technologies that should
be increased and everything else should
be reduced if people want a mortgage
they should get it from a non-bank
lender and banks should not be allowed
to
to invest in that so that's how you you
make sure only existing money is used
for asset transactions you then you
don't get asset inflation
and you make sure small businesses have
enough money by helping the small local
community banks america has a lot of
those they need to be supported by the
central bank not the big banks now
actually
we can compare now to to china i think
which is an interesting example because
they used to be you know essentially
stalinist type soviet union type economy
in the 60s and then early 70s then in
1978 deng xiao deng xiaoping came to
power
and you know what he did what was the
biggest thing he did
that
created this success of the chinese
economy
he traveled to japan he went going to
these um evening these dinners um with
the japanese drinking a lot of uh sake
and and multi
and he got the truth out of them about
window guidance and that you can use
this window guidance tool for good
if you make sure banks
first of all that there's a lot of banks
a lot of small banks and the banks
create credit
mainly for business investment
and so when he came back and he rose to
power after 1978
in china what he did is he created a lot
of banks he started with this soviet
system of one bank monobank the central
bank
but then he created thousands of banks
small banks community banks savings
banks regional banks provincial banks
a few national champions as well but
now china has almost 5 000 banks almost
as many as the u.s and that created
these 40 years of double-digit economic
growth multiplying national income so
and that is very capitalist to have
small local banks
that generates a capitalist economy why
because
you see the money supply
creation process actually belongs to all
of us it's our privilege and if a
central institution is making these
decisions that's never good it needs to
be decentralized and the best way is to
have small local banks you can watch
what they're doing you can attend their
meetings you can ask you can hold them
to account if they if they suddenly
support a strange project locals can
influence them right
you just flipped in 20 minutes you just
flip because 20 minutes ago you said
what they did was right because the
money wasn't felt or seen in that
situation where we already have the
wrong system which is so centralized but
i'm against the centralized system
that's i'm telling you
i i see you you said this massive
government intervention rather than the
econ rather the economist says that the
more relevant comparison is what
happened from march 2020 is much more
akin to certain uh
certainly centrally planned stalinist
soviet union types restrictions in what
scenarios what we have is massive
innovation by the government and the
economy by introducing restriction
including price controls on so many
parts of the economy as we've never seen
before in the uk right we're seeing that
also in the u.s well exactly and that's
what i'm criticizing i know you are but
but but you also saying what they did
with 2008 was the right move and you
said if you would have done it
differently you would have done it
slightly differently but you're still
supporting the central bank getting more
power but you see there's a sequence
they had created this acid bubble with
their centralized bad system and bad
policies once you have created this it's
like you're falling over your bike
should i not help you so you don't crash
yes i help you quickly and you're saying
oh you should intervene and shouldn't
help me well look i know you can quickly
solve this problem but the bigger story
is we need to shift away from the
centralization that the central planners
love that's not good and we need to
decentralize and the best way to do this
is establish
local community banks new small banks
then we get the centralized the
the decentralized system and that's what
made even china successful they moved
from the soviet system i would have only
i would have done it in a in a way of
uh uh let all the
however many companies you got like i
remember when aig was going through aig
had a fleet of planes that they're
sitting on
aig owns planes yes go look it up aig
had a fleet of planes that the new ceos
like bob and moshe what are we doing
what business are we in and bob ben
moshe comes in and cleans house
and does what he does the 183 billion
and the 21 billion dollars of interest
he pays back within three to five years
seven years whatever the timeline was
but if some of these companies that are
bigger companies i'm sitting there
saying do you specialize in planes no
sell them do you specialize in this nose
what do what is your core
competency what are you doing here's if
you want any kind of help i'm okay with
your hundreds big companies small
companies within a big company i'm okay
with you selling these to these other
people but you can't sit around doing
this because you don't know how to
operate companies i want more companies
than a few people that are controlling
the entire marketplace which is what
happens every time we bail out they end
up buying some of these other companies
and get more and more powerful so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]